I was always a bit late in dating scene
anyways like my first and only boyfriend
was when I was 22. I was with him for
two years I honestly thought this was
someone I was going to marry that's how
serious I was but guess what he was a
narcissist he gaslighted me all the time
his whole family was yeah was he
diagnosed
um he's very self-centered and
everything was about it but he was never
diagnosed because okay because like
again this in a way is an excuse like
with that women use because if he hasn't
seen a therapist and he hasn't been
professionally diagnosed you can't
diagnose him as a narcissist I think
it's difficult because I it's not it's
not difficult you know it's like if he
if he hasn't been diagnosed as a
narcissist we can't just go around
calling people narcissists